afraid of the answer to these questions
can left and right wing people ever
meaningfully communicate with each other
and I'm wondering if you didn't call it
a little bit about temper mentality and
the differences therein that's what they
do in a democracy
look the lefties they're high in
openness and low in conscientiousness
and that means they don't like
responsibility that much but they're
pretty damn creative and they're not
very orderly especially they're not very
orderly and that's part of
conscientiousness by the way and so
they're good at being artists and
they're going to being entrepreneurs but
they're terrible at running things
but then the Conservatives on the other
side they're low in openness which is
the trait creativity that doesn't mean
they're stupid by the way it just means
they're there they're there thinking
isn't as freeform let's put it that way
and so it's more constrained and they're
high in conscientiousness especially
orderliness so the damn good at running
things that already work so you need the
Liberals there wouldn't be high openness
low conscientiousness if there wasn't a
niche for it and you need the
Conservatives and and sometimes the
Liberals are right no borders should be
more open cuz that's their fundamental
claim and sometimes the Conservatives
are right the borders between things
should be more closed and and because
they're both right some of the time and
because the environment keeps sneaking
around you have to have dialogue between
the two sources constantly constantly so
that the polity can orient itself as the
snake of the environment moves and
that's why you need free speech and so
the left and the right get along
perfectly well together as long as they
can talk to each other but as soon as
they can't talk to each other then the
alternative there's only one or two
alternatives to negotiation simple is
that one is slavery the other is tyranny
so if those you cannot negotiate with
will either become your slaves or your
tyrants so you wipe out free speech then
that's what you're left with and that's
why I free speech isn't just another
right for Christ's sake not just another
right how dumb can you be to think that
you don't know anything if you think
that it's the mechanism by which people
of different opinions talk instead of
strangling each other so and but if you
want them to strangle each other which
you might
and really you might then take away the
right to express their opinion and watch
the whole thing go up in flames and go
like this because maybe that's what a
big part of you want